welcome to my tutorial on how to make a
paper Japanese crane making the crane
involves some new advanced folds but I
will go through step-by-step on how to
make it what you're going to need is a
piece of printer paper if you have
origami or square paper that should work
fine also and scissors are going to be
optional as I said previously I'd also
like to teach you how to make the paper
rocket ship so be sure to subscribe by
clicking the button up to the right for
notification of my future videos to make
the crane we're going to need a piece of
square paper so what we do with printer
paper is we take one of these corners
and we fold it until it's on this edge
here and you want to be as neat as
possible and line it up edge to edge
all right so once you've made that
crease then you can cut off this excess
paper so that we have a square piece of
paper and you want to be as neat as
possible just so you have a nice
straight edge alright so now what you
should have is a piece of square paper
that has a diagonal fold in it so now we
want to take this paper and we're going
to fold it in half this way by lining up
the edges and then we're going to make a
crease then we can open up the paper
again and then we want to fold it in
half going this way
all right so now if you open the paper
you should have what looks like a
diagonal fold and then you should have a
cross right in the middle so now what we
do is we're going to fold the paper in
half along this diagonal line that we
made previously and just make sure it's
nice and flat and then we're going to
kind of lift up this first layer and
we're going to tuck this corner piece
down here so make sure you're holding it
like this and you lift up this first
layer of paper and you tuck this corner
down in the middle here
and then you want to make sure that
that's nice and flat in the middle on
that new fold so you just make a crease
and then you do the same for the left
side so you want to tuck this corner
inside just like that fold this flap
down and then we make another crease so
now you should have a paper that looks
something like this and if you made
really good creases when you were
tucking the corners in then you should
see a faint line that runs vertically
down the middle of this diamond so what
we want to do is we want to take the
corner of this paper the first layer and
we're going to fold it so that this edge
here is on that line that runs
vertically
so you should have something that looks
like that and you want to do that for
the remaining three flaps so take this
one hold it up there and make a crease
flip it over and do the same for these
two all right this next fold that I'm
going to show you which is known as the
petal fold is one of the trickiest folds
of making the crane what we want to do
is we want to first unfold these folds
which we just made and we want to
flatten it out so it is again in a
diamond shape flip it over and do the
same for this side now we want to do is
we want to take this corner here this
first layer and we want to lift it up
just like this and what we're going to
do is we're going to kind of pull on it
until these corners start to tuck in
word so once they start to tuck inward
what you want to do is you want to take
it and you want to kind of crease it
along that line which we previously made
and then you want to flatten it out just
like that so that's called the petal
fold and as you'll see you kind of have
this petal structure so you want to
flatten it out and you're going to do
the same for the other side take this
corner lift it up as you'll see the
paper might not want to fold there so
what you got to do is you take your
thumb and you just just pop it outward
so that these corner pieces can tuck
inward toward the center of the diamond
okay so then you should be able to kind
of flatten it down and fold these corner
pieces directly into the center and then
again you want to make really good
creases and flatten it out all the way
once you've done that you should have a
structure that looks something like this
and as you'll see you should be able to
kind of separate the bottom halves of
this diamond structure while the top are
going to stay solid so you want these
two halves to face down we're just like
that and what we're going to do is we're
going to take each of these corner
pieces here and we're going to fold them
in towards the middle so that this edge
here is going to line up with the
vertical edge that goes down the middle
so you want to take it and you're going
to fold that so that it lines up just
like that make a crease and you should
have something that looks like that
so you want to do that for the remaining
three take the corner fold it in towards
the middle and you make a crease flip it
over and do the same for the last two
all right so we're almost finished
making the crane all we have to do now
is to make the head and tail and also
fold the wings down so what we want to
do is you want to just hold it on the
side and open these two flaps then we
want to take this and we want to fold it
upwards all the way until it can't go
any more and you want to kind of have
this line here along with this line and
you want to make a crease on the bottom
and then you want to just close these
two flaps on it and you want it to fold
the other way so you can kind of bring
it out and make sure it folds the other
way also and just make really good
creases and make sure it's flat should
have something that looks like that do
the same for the other side fold it
upwards make a crease close it on it and
then we want to just make sure that this
the head or tail is going to be folded
that way it's okay if it's a little if
it's a little off just make sure it's
flat all right so now all you have to do
is take one of these points and to fold
it to make a head so you take one of
these and you just fold it downward and
then you're going to just pinch it like
that now you have a head and then the
tail is fine just like that so now all
you have to do is to fold down the wings
and there you go you have your paper
crane now if you want to round off the
wings a little bit that's fine so it
looks more like that and to make it
stand what you do is you just kind of
bend these out and then you could have a
standing paper crane okay so I hope you
were able to make your paper crane and
that you enjoyed the tutorial please
rate and comment below to let me know
what you thought and also if you would
like to see how to make the paper
rocketship as well thanks for watching
guys